in 2006 in New York City public school
teacher named Paul Edelman launched
Teachers Pay Teachers
an online platform that lets educators
sell digital copies of their classroom
materials for small amounts of money in
the past four years growth sales have
ballooned to 44 million dollars it's
booming we are growing ami burner is the
head of community and editorial for
Teachers Pay Teachers we get significant
new users weekly for public school
teachers whose pay generally reflects
not their talent and drive but the
number of years they've served in the
classroom the site is bringing a
refreshing dose of market incentives
1332 teachers have earned more than five
thousand dollars selling their materials
on teachers pay teacher's and 164 have
earned more than $50,000 the top seller
and the site's breakout star is deanna
jump a kindergarten teacher from Macon
Georgia by selling activities and lesson
plans like guided reading and writing
through the year along with a hundred
and forty-five other products so far
Deana jump has earned two million
dollars on Teachers Pay Teachers her
little ideas might never have left her
class robbed worried not for a chance
conversation with another teacher and
she said your stuff is so good you have
got to get it on teachers pay teachers
as soon as she started earning big
profits jump purchased a
handicap-accessible van for her
quadriplegic brother jr some of our top
sellers they're kind of rock stars and
they've built a brand but their brand is
that it's like this is a real teacher
and she's succeeding because she's
exceptional the site is so popular
because it's addressing a major problem
in public education schools often fail
to provide their staffs with basic
classroom materials leaving them to
invent their own lesson plans from
scratch even when there are tens of
thousands of other educators around the
country teaching the exact same subjects
Teachers Pay Teachers gives the
opportunity to use your professional
expertise to assess this is right for my
classroom and then you know maybe you're
changing it by creating an introduction
and maybe you're doing a little activity
afterwards but why are you
you know all that time creating
something that someone else has spent a
lot of time working on through the power
of a peer-to-peer community teachers pay
teachers gives educators something
that's been largely stripped away by
union contracts and browbeating
bureaucrats the dignity of being treated
like a professional I'm actually being
respected for the expert that I am
calling it a revolution in education I
don't think is is overstating it really